okay so you want to grow your investor
list
you want to package and sell deals but
you don't know where to find investors
you don't know how to grow your investor
list how to qualify your investors
so i'm going to break this down i'm
going to keep this really really really
simple okay
three questions you need to ask
investors the real key is people say
that they need more investors
they don't need more investors what they
need is they need more investors
that are actually prepared to buy from
them we don't need more investors
investors are there i mean if you go
down to the facebook group property
investors with samuel leeds
like 30 000 investors
so if i say to you oh you need more
investors
go down to the facebook group you're
going to say that's helpful but
and i need investors that are actually
prepared to buy from me
i need investors that have got money and
and
and and are prepared to be on my mailing
list pay me a finder's fee
i need investors that are prepared to
act quick okay so
how do you not find investors i just
told you how to find 30
000 investors i mean geez when people
sometimes i have it when people come to
my events
there'll be there'll be there'll be 100
people in the room or a thousand people
in the room
and guess what everybody is in the room
they're all an investor okay or they're
an inspiring investor some of them are a
qualified investor some of them have
been in the game for 20 years some of
them have been in the game for 20
minutes
but i've been around with a thousand
people someone will stand up say
something i've got a question i'll be
like yep and i'll say
how do i find investors i'm like look
around the room
there's a thousand people around the
room they're here
right in front of your eyes so when
people say to me how do i find investors
i think what they really mean is
how do i get investors on my books
that are ready and willing to pay me a
fee
so if that's what you're looking for
then there's three things that you need
to ask
investors okay so go on the facebook
group
go to the training program go to the
networking event
find investors which is the easy bit but
then you need to ask them three
questions
the first question is you need to ask
them what they're looking to invest in
so are you a property investor you
probably are because you're a
property investing networking event so
what is it that you're looking to buy
now if they say to you oh i'm actually
just getting started
and i'm looking to buy a rent to rent
deal because i've not really got any
money
or actually i'm not looking to invest
right now i'm looking to learn how to
find deals so i can package and sell
deals to other people then you know
they've not really got any money
and they're probably not going to be an
investor that can be on your
investor list that's ready to pay you
money that's the very first question
if they say yeah i'm an investor and i'm
looking for hmos in birmingham that's
the first question
tick great you know they're actually an
investor
and then and and you know what they're
looking for so then you go to the second
question number two
where you're gonna say stump great um
i'm a deal
if i was to find you a hmo in birmingham
if i was to find you a below market
value deal in middlesbrough if i was to
find you a development opportunity in
leicester
you're just going to repeat whatever it
was that they said they're looking to
invest in
would you like me to send you the
details over and you can take a look at
it
boom that's question number two so
question one
is what are you looking to invest in and
at that point
they're either gonna pass the test or
they're gonna fail the test
they're either gonna let you know that
they're actually a serious investor
they've got a bit of money
and they're looking for development
opportunities in leicester or they're
going to say oh actually
i'm not really ready to invest in
anything
question number two of the pre-qualifier
is
oh you're looking for and you're going
to repeat what they just said
i'm a deal sorcerer if i find anything
that might might
might be a repeat what they just said do
you want me to send you an email with
the details
and if they say yes to that question
you're then going to go great and you're
going to take their details
you're going to take their business card
you can take the email and you're going
to put
put it on your phone on your notes
section and say i'll add you to my my
database
and then you've got just a third
question and the third question is
oh and by the way i'll send an email if
i find something that
ticks the box and works perfect for you
are you in a position where you can
actually proceed
what do you mean by that i mean can they
pay can they pay your finders fee
can they pay um for the house have they
got money
he's gonna ask them that's the question
you're not gonna say do you have money
in your bank you're just gonna say are
you in a position where you can proceed
if the ideal opportunity comes along
does someone know if they say yes to
that
you've got yourself an investor to a
qualified
investor on your list ready to buy from
you
you only need 10 of those just gotta ask
those
three questions okay so put yourself in
a room
of investors even if it's a virtual room
even if it's a facebook group build
relationships get talking to people
and then just ask them what are you
looking to invest in great
if i find something suitable do you want
me to send it to you great
and lastly if i was to find something
essentially
are you in a position where you can
proceed because if you are i'll go and
look for something for you
you are brilliant well look my fee is um
approximately about two thousand pounds
i i'm going to be in the area next week
i'll have a look and i'll give you a
call and then suddenly you've got a
qualified investor
so don't don't don't get don't get
troubled that you haven't got any
investors
find investors and then qualify them by
asking those three questions
let me know how you get on and i hope to
see you succeed as a deal saucer
thanks so much i'll see you next time